♪ ♪ ♪
- Beaucoup d'amis et de proches
ont sisisté vendredi
aux funérailles
de Jannai Dopwell-Baile, mais
aucun représentant
des gouvernements. Le jeune sans
histoire a été poignardé à mort
le 18 octobre dans
le stationnement de son école
par des inconnus cagoulés.
TYRESE DOPWELL-BAILEY,
frère de Jannai
- Trois gars avec des masques
s s ont fait ça...
à quelqu'un qui est vraiment
gentil et comme... gentil avec
tout le monde. C'est dur à juste
parler, just to talk about it,
c'est vraiment... hard.
- Tyrese adorait son petit frère
qui apprenait à jouer du piano
et rêvait de devenir rappeur.
Caiaiairement à la médisance
qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux, le jeune Jannai n'avait
aucun lien avec des gangs ou
des bandes de voyous.
Sa tante dénonce le traitement
médiatique de ce meurtre d'une
violence inouïe, en plein jour.
- "Au lieu de venir découvrir
qui était cet enfant, dit-elle,
vous l'avez dépeint comme
le membre d'un gang."
EMILIE NICOLAS,cofondatrice, Quf
- Ça a eu une influence très
douloureuse sur la famille
de Jannai de sentir que sa vie
compte moins q
celle d'un autre jeune, que
leur deuil compte moins que
celle d'un autre jeune.
- Cette fausse association
expliquerait qu'il y ait eu
moins d'empathie, moins
d'indignation publique envers
ce meurtre sordide, comparées
aux réactions qui ont suivies
celui du jeune Thomas Trudel,
tiré à bout portant près de chez
lui. Un double standard assez
fréquent dans les médias, selon
cette militante antiraciste.
- On est habitué,
dans les médias, à associer
les visages des personnes noires
à diririririres de criminalité,
donc les gens associent tout
de suite les deux. Ce qui fait
que quand un jeune homme noir
de 16 ans meurt on se dit :
"Est-ce que c'est nenenenenel?"
"Est-ce que c'est lui qui a été
violent?"
Ce genre de questions-là se
posent, alors que quand un jeune
e e e e e blanc du même âge meu,
c'est pas tout de suite
l'hypothèse qui nous vient
en tête.
- Thomas Trudel et Jannai, c'est
la même chose qui est arrivée.
La même chose. C'était du
violence.
- La famille de Jannai
avait invité la mairesse
Valérie Plante teteteteteter
à la vigile organisée
en sa mémoire. Elle a plutôt
envoyé deux représentantes.
En la voyant, la semaine
dernière, rendre hommage à
Thomas Trudel en compagnie du
chef de police. Ils ont eu mal.
- "Je comprends leur douleur,
dit-elle, chaque mort en est une
de trop, mais pour moi, il n'y a
pas de double standard dans
la protection de nos jeunes.
- Le premier ministre a publié
dimaagagagagagagage sur
la violence par armes à feu en
nommant deux jeunes assassinés
récemment. Son silence sur
la mort de Jannai Dopwell-Baile
a soulevé un tollé qui l'a fààà.
- J'ai pas voulu exclure qui que
ce soit. Les parents...je peux
pas imaginer la situation dans
laquelle ils se trouvent de
perdre un adolescent.
- Sa famille espère que
souvenir qu'on gardera de Jannai
est celui d'un garçon gentil,
qui aimait Star Wars, l'homme
araignée, la musique et
qui aurait voulu être
Ici Sophie Langlois
Radio-Canada, Montréal